bioinformatics for genomic medicine is a
new initiative
in africa and an opportunity to learn
about the future of medicine
and see how big data computational
biology
data analysis curation and
interpretation are all
key to improved health and a solution
for the growing needs of patients and
healthcare systems around the world
this program will support a growing need
for data analysis skills
amongst biomedical researchers
university students
and industry professionals the upcoming
onyx logic training program on
bioinformatics for genomic medicine
is where you can learn about the role of
big data in basic and translational
biomedical research
we will do so using examples from
chronic and acute infectious diseases
we will see the increasing significance
of novel high throughput data
technologies like next generation
sequencing
and the application of omics data
analysis to diagnostics and treatment
selection
today i'd like to introduce you to this
online training that our team
will be launching this month in
collaboration with medlab convo
and graduates of our online
international programs
that deeply care about the need for
quality bioinformatics education
across africa together with our partners
we designed this program for biologists
clinicians and researchers or students
that are interested in advancing their
understanding of big data in life
science research
this introductory program will not
require
many of the typical prerequisites that
include
computational biology training no need
for
coding proficiency or expertise in
bioinformatics and biostatistics
in fact anyone with a basic familiarity
with cell and molecular biology and an
interest in the future of genomic
medicine
will be able to learn about and apply
big data analytics tools to relevant
data sets
as a result of the short focused and
effective program
we will combine online sessions
self-guided study materials
and practical assignments for an
immersive experience
that has proven to be effective and are
well known and respected
on mclogic academic programs moreover
the support and coordination team will
include some of the brightest and most
energetic partners
i have had a chance to work with
emmanuel anya awa
team lead at metlab convo nigeria
adekunle a de la hoya
faculty at leeds city university and our
own mohit mizunder
so what is the future of medicine with
increasing availability of data
expansion and standardization of high
throughput sequencing
medicine of the future is both more
personalized and precise
driven by data and an integrated
analytics solution
let's take a look at some of these
trends that are leading to a disruption
across all aspects of the traditional
healthcare delivery system
with increased reliance on data and
lower costs of generating detailed and
large data sets
at each clinical interaction we are
faced with an explosion
in data availability however a growing
informational lag
complicates the translation of this data
to practical
and impactful insights at the point of
care this is what we call the analysis
gap
the difference between our ability to
generate new data
and the ability to analyze and interpret
it for the benefit of the individual
patients
as a result there is a disconnect
between lab technicians
researchers and clinicians that form the
biomedical research ecosystem
this disconnect breaks up the cycle of
innovation
due to the lack of data-driven research
skills among otherwise effective
biomedical personnel
that is dealing with increasing demands
in a changing
unpredictable landscape we can see this
gap clearly in this current pandemic
that is affecting every continent
and keeping clinicians epidemiologists
pharmaceutical companies
and even whole governments puzzled the
rate
quality and scale of generated data in
this pandemic has been unprecedented
billions of dollars have been spent to
characterize the virus
and make this data available to the
greater research community
if used properly it can lead to the
development of vaccines
drugs and better diagnostic tests and
yet
over 20 million people have been
infected with thousands of lethal
outcomes
and there's still no clarity about the
future can students and researchers
around the world be empowered to do such
analysis themselves
and share their insights at the local
regional national
and international level this pandemic
has already disrupted health care
but many other more subtle trends and
chronic disease management
rising costs of drug development and
increased fear of communicable diseases
that continue to spread in a changing
climate are exposing the weakness
of this biomedical ecosystem that have
traditionally been driven by
large-scale research projects today the
decentralized data-driven
science is key to the future of clinical
as well as biotechnological innovation
to close this gap we have to focus on
the central issues
that define the future of medicine
people
that work in this field by offering
training support
and effective tools to manage process
analyze and
integrate desperate types of healthcare
data
we can make a lasting impact and change
the future of medicine
that is why this program is built to
provide students of all backgrounds with
a clear perspective on big data
analytics
machine learning and artificial
intelligence and application
to onyx data and the research clinical
and industry applications
our omixlogix step-by-step process is
enabled
by access to complex tools via a simple
and intuitive interface
at the same time exposing participants
to analysis logic
in the context of real data sets and
extrapolation of this logic
to a variety of projects and data sets
with assistance from mentors
and technical support the program is
designed to highlight the role
of big omics data that is shaping modern
biomedical innovation where molecular
data is used for precision diagnostics
big data integration
machine learning and transforming
personalization of treatment selection
and innovative algorithms allow for
unprecedented capabilities
with drug discovery design and
repurposing
the various types of such omics data
describe
in great detail intracellular and
intercellular processes
associated with common diseases these
datasets can be analyzed to understand
the biology behind
host factors and microbiome composition
in our bodies
as well as the environments that we live
in to drive infection and cause
deterioration of health and the
destabilization of the immune system
that can lead to clinical manifestations
of disease
to study such data each type has to flow
through a series of steps
combining into bioinformatics pipelines
that have to be applied with
understanding such analysis
structures data and can be further
studied to understand
how genomic elements are associated with
clinical phenotypes
clinical information derived from such
analysis can include
risk stratification for patients
treatment selection
as well as innovation in target
therapies that are poised to make a huge
difference in how
complex diseases can be treated with
minimal side effects and maximum
efficacy we will use in this program
a case study approach and provide
examples of publicly available data sets
to learn about these topics in each
example we will use a condition
experiment or even an epidemic outbreak
to study
available data and learn about genomic
data analysis
and clinical phenotypes rate of
infection
disease spread or the integration of
data to predict
best treatment options we will look at
into available genomic data
and how it can help us study diseases
like covet 19
a single strand rna virus from the
coronation family
analyzing such genomic data from
publicly accessible repositories
we will learn about viral detection and
the origin
structure function and pathogenesis of
this new pathogen
this includes accurate detection and
characterization of cancer-driving
infections like the epstein-barr virus
human papilloma virus or hepatitis c and
b
which cause over a million of new cancer
cases
every year these kinds of technologies
and the associated need
and bioinformatics skills has already
led
to many important applications in
clinical and pharmaceutical industries
where such skills are in high demand
bioinformaticians
can help extract biologically meaningful
information from data that is often
complex and requires many analysis steps
to explore patterns develop questions
that can be asked from data
ask these questions using analytical
methods and
find answers that can be validated so
that's why we're inviting you
to join this program it will be held
online with one hour online sessions
as well as self-paced materials that are
available through our project-based
educational portal
these three sessions will include
next-generation sequencing big data in
life sciences
how can bioinformatics help us diagnose
and treat infectious diseases
and genomic medicine in and post the era
of covet 19. on september 14th
we will speak about the history of omics
data and its significance
review the entire course and explore the
tools and resources that the program
will offer
on september 15th we will talk about how
bioinformatics can help us diagnose and
treat infectious diseases
where we'll discuss precision medicine
in the era of
viral diseases on september 18th
we will discuss genomic medicine in and
post code 19
where we'll discuss novel coronavirus
genes proteins and the virology of the
disease
and how the data and the various
analysis tools can help in the detection
comparison and diagnosis of different
viral strains
and the identification of the impact of
mutations on the functionality of viral
proteins
to join this program you have to
complete the registration and start
updating your profile
on the educational portal once you have
done that you can start with free
courses
and look into the online courses that
will be offered
for the duration of the program our
previous participants have benefited
from this kind of training
applying what they have learned to their
areas of expertise
including a number of participants that
are currently involved
in biomedical research and even clinical
applications of such
insights in their field once you
complete the registration
you will also receive an account on the
t bioinfo
big data analytical platform for
bioinformatics
big data analysis the program is now
open for registration
after you complete the program you will
receive a certificate of participation
or a certificate of excellence if you
also include
an independent project in your
submission
bioinformatics for genomic medicine is
an opportunity to learn about the future
of medicine and see how big data
computational biology data analysis
curation
and interpretation are all key to
improve healthcare
and a solution for the growing needs of
patients and healthcare systems around
the world
we hope that you join us